so
a question first like how many people
are actually maintaining an open source
project how many people i wanted to rage
quit
they're open source yeah me too it seems
to be the kind of like general term when
it comes to you you get to this point
where you kind of just
really don't want to deal with your
project anymore and then something
happens like for me they started paying
me to
do it and now i have to do it because
it's the way i get food on the table
so um how did i get into
um well it was really fast how did i get
into node.js
so i was actually at rubicon here in
berlin in like 2000
and uh was it like 2009 or something
like that
yeah something like no 2007 actually and
we were talking about
the i think v8 have just been announced
and it was like all over the internet
and stuff and i was talking to a friend
and i was like
so how long do you think it's gonna take
before somebody writes a javascript
framework right for the server and i was
like i don't know but it's gonna be cool
right
and i did a little thing put up a google
alert and like
i think it was like a little bit later
like uh nearly two years later
uh so my google alert went off and said
like hey node.js is out
and i was like oh look it's javascript
on the server but it's
not exactly what i expected from coming
from ruby it was like a synchronous huh
right so that was like the big big shock
and i got intrigued right
and i decided to like start playing
around with it and wrote my own little
applications
and i came to a time where i basically
had to need to store some data somewhere
and at that point there was only ryan's
pg
javascript script that was like a simple
postgres driver
wasn't really fast wasn't really any
particularly
you know full-form platform at that
point and i was kind of looking around
and a friend of mine
ruby guy had been using mongodb down in
atlanta for our project
and said like why don't you use this
it's like json right
and so i'll say okay let me start write
my own driver since you basically have
to do everything yourself at this point
because i don't know how many people
were in the node community at that time
but
a couple of hundred maybe so
after a couple of months the first
commit was that
in like january 7 2010
and since then it's just been crazy
right
and specifically last year the last 12
months like
the growth in usage for for node.js
projects in general or
npm modules has just exploded right
mongodb is kind of like
it's exception like i mean we've gone
from like about 20 000
npm installs to about like 200 000 a
month or something
i think socket io uh i think uh redis is
probably
the biggest one i think it's got about
400 000 installs
a month but it's just gone
gangbusters and i kind of expect this
trend to keep going in the next couple
years
so how was the first driver when it came
out it was
a total piece of all right so
it had things like a hashtag ordered
hash class
that i had written because i you know i
i was relying i
didn't want to rely on the behavior of
v8 and ordering keys
and it was completely horrible structure
mess like it was just
me learning to write javascript
basically and there wasn't really any
testing frameworks at that point so i
had to kind of hack
up jspec to make it work so i could have
some testing framework
the other thing was like node was like
liquid water right
everything was constantly changing like
from one point release to the other
like philosophies would change all right
so i don't know how many people here
love promises but that was initially in
node
and then they took it out i don't
remember exactly why the reason was but
um it was taken out and
yeah there was no npm at that point at
all right so
everything you did you basically had to
kind of uh download jas and put it in
the right
directories yourself and stuff like that
so there's no real way
of distributing the driver either people
just had to basically clone your git
repository and
and use the driver so the kind of
challenge is you kind of run
into when you're driving writing
something like a driver and javascript
no in 64 support i was just in the
javascript
um crypto talk here and he said that
uh he mentioned that there's likely
there's a ww3
crypto library our crypto api may be
coming that might have
in 64s that would be a revelation for
for me
but the problem and this is something
you're going to run into eventually as
the javascript developer
is that the numbers aren't really
numbers they're actually floats right
they're double floats
which means that anything over 53 bits
cannot be represented as a whole integer
in fact when you reach that number it
just keeps being the same number over
and over and over again right
so to represent 64-bit uh
ins which we need for to support all of
the mongodb kind of
types you have to use the google long
closure library
and that works pretty well it's a bit
slow because you have to do all this
64-bit arithmetic over two 32-bit
values but it works but i was a pain
so then we started kind of adding
features because i was sort of evolving
the driver as mongodb itself was adding
features so we had that
great fest which is like storing files
in the database
uh there they came up with like
clustering which called replicas
in mongodb and then later sharding and
so i had to add support for that
and then adding streams support for
cursor and great fest when that became
kind of like the big meme in in ogs and
it kind of became more standard
and dealing with complicated issues like
high availability
then after a while you know like you get
into this mark
i want to like optimize stuff and the c
plus
apis have finally kind of like
solidified enough for you to go and
write a c plus plus
extension and there was actually enough
tutorials so people actually had tried
at that point so i decided to profile
the application
and then look at like where the hotspot
in the code was and at that point the
whole parser was javascript
and it was actually the bottleneck was
the parser right
so i wrote a horrible c plus plus parser
because i'm not a cps plus person
thankfully there was a guy in lucasart
made the rest in peace
that cleaned up the code later and now i
think it's a fairly solid
parser a couple of things
that i did wrong was that for example
initial version implemented these types
that are immortally being
like a binary class or a long type of
this kind of stuff
we implemented in c plus and that was
just hard as hell to maintain
right whereas like every time somebody
changed me
sent me a bug fix for something like i
had to go back and see plus plus and fix
that code as well
and in the end it didn't mean anything
there was no performance benefit there
any at all because
in the end it wasn't expensive to
actually instantiate just javascript
classes
inside of v8 c plus plus code and just
use those
so now the parser c plus plus parser
just deals with the actual parsing but
still just using the javascript objects
for the types
which means i don't have to maintain as
much code
then like as node.js was liquid suddenly
they introduced buffers
right and buffers was like a massive
improvement right
also because the google v8 team wiselov
in these guys
actually went the other way to make it
be fast for node.js
so one of the things you kind of have to
do with
buffers like for example is to be aware
that like allocating buffers can be
expensive and so when you're doing
something like a bison serialization
you have to allocate some sort of binary
buffer
of some particular size the way mongodb
documents are nested documents you kind
of have to walk the tree to determine
the size of the final
buffer and it's actually faster to
iterate through the entire tree
allocate once a big piece of slab of
memory
sterilize into that memory and then
write it out then to try to
basically you know plug a bunch of
smaller buffers together
because the cost of allocating all those
small things is quite expensive
actually in fact like one of the
experience i'm considering is just to
allocate
the maximum size of bison i can do and
just use that buffer again and again
all the time and just never actually
allocate any memory
other than once so i'm c i think that
might be
able to break uh get to see uh the
javascript version up to c plus plus
speed
so one of the things you have to know
about buffers is that they're up they
have a secret optimization v8 so if you
ever do like uh
uh profiling in ogs you'll you're going
to see these things called slow buff
and fast buff show up and fastbuff
basically lets you map
directly into memory so if you do
something like entry if the buffer is
called a
element 0 and then set it to a byte
value it actually will go straight into
memory instead of going through the
entire stack of v8s
so that's also uh based on what type
arrays do so type arrays are
equivalent in this respect to like
performance wise
that's it i don't know if uh eventually
buffers might even go away or be
implemented just on top of
existing type arrays but that's
something to ask for node.js people
the other thing you have to deal with is
like pool handling so when you're a
database you've got lots of connections
you have to check in stuff check it out
you can't really do that in a efficient
way and
just because blocking isn't really an
option right
so spice must flow um
also in in manga db you basically have a
situation called a right concern so
traditionally mongodb basically wrote a
message
like an insert to the straight to the
socket out to the database
and to actually get the result of that
insert you have to write a second
message called get last error right
after
right so they get last error and the
thing has to happen one after the other
because the socket is bound to a
specific thread so if you put something
else in between
and then you get last error you're
basically going to get the
result from the the operation that
happened but not the one that you wanted
so the thing to do that is at least not
just was to pipeline it right so you
write the up and then get that area into
one single binary buffer and flush it
out
the socket then we get problems like
how to deal with reconnects all right so
you have a cluster
the servers one of the servers disappear
now you have need to reconnect but
mongodb isn't blocking like
in typical traditional synchronous
languages like
python you might just wait for the
server to come back and then like
block all operations until you're
basically ready to
write to that server so node.js
basically what it does is that in a
cluster
when the secondary goes down it starts
buffering up the operations and
until there is like basically an
available server
and then it flushes those operations out
to
that server so in the best case what
you're going to see is just a
increase in latency on your operations
but you're not going to lose any
operations
the problem is obviously if your service
is out long enough
you're going to get you're going to run
out buffer or memory space basically
so there's still this kind of like
balance between one another here that i
haven't quite figured out the other
thing that people
were wanted was the ability to kind of
like
just serialize an object but not
necessarily just let the
sterilizer decide which fields were to
be serialized right
so there was a need to way this was
actually people came to me and and
and committed part of this code the idea
was just to add something
like a to be some thing so like if you
actually have an object and you add a
two b zone function
in that function whatever you return is
what gets serialized
so it makes it a little bit easier to
kind of make your own kind of like semi
odm style thing where you can kind of
keep fields
transitive in the in the documents and
not necessarily have to write them to
disk
and this was like a very simple thing
but that it actually got a lot of like
use for a lot of people
so we were talking about the fact that
we have these clusters on replica sets
they come and go marcus server so you
have
these secondaries in mongodb which are
basically
slaves in the in the terminology of
normal databases
and you have these problems where you
basically have to query
once in a while the state of the replica
set to figure out if some new node
came into production right because the
amount of the b you can kind of say
i'm going to boot up a new database and
i'm going to add that to
this cluster and the driver needs to be
able to pick that up and basically
include that as possible way server to
read from
and in the application itself you can
basically say
let me read from a slave all my
reads to go to slave and not to the
actual master
so this is where the main problem comes
with node yes right
for this particular use case a single
thread just sucks
all right like you can use set time of
the set interval
but it's not really that good it's like
a yankee way of doing it
because there's no hard this really
really soft kind of like
it's very very very soft uh guarantees
on sets time i don't set interval
on it running on a specific specific
time so if you're just hammering
your node.js application with javascript
you might
the set time of the set to one second
might take longer than one second
and there's lots of subtle state changes
that can happen in between
and i don't think we're ever going to
get web workers in ogs i hope so but i'm
not holding my breath
and there's not really an option of
using processes because
i imagine a driver that starts spinning
off processes without your knowledge
that's probably not going to be a
popular
driver and the other thing that i ran
into was
when node.js went multi-platform right
hello windows users anybody here is a
windows user
wow there's actually a couple of ads
that's amazing so now just goes windows
all right what about that damn c
plus plus right anybody here your
windows users
enjoy c plus plus extensions
no so
so what you do in this case like you you
install um
you install a driver node git will throw
an error
it will still install but it will throw
an error so you get this confusion going
right
so you build dlls uh in case uh i built
dls automatically for windows 32 and
windows 64
and just wrap you know package them with
with the actual driver so that like if
you're on windows you will go and look
is there a dll
load that and you'll use the c plus
parser
but there's all these yankee things i've
probably improved a little bit but for
example
until recently you could only build node
extensions using visual studio 2010 plus
the windows 7 64-bit sdk
just finding that out is like a question
itself
and you know nodegib will basically
give an error that the package didn't
build leading to
my you know typical github issues where
i cannot install the module
because i'm getting an error right even
if the module installed
so usually the problem is between
you know the screen and the seats
but sometimes they have a valid point so
one of my biggest perfumes i guess
is that i would love to see be able to
tell no chip
don't build for windows right and and
then like just uh
have it installed properly and it
ignores basically the build process
and then you have the random people who
are still using
windows xp like who the hell uses
windows xp
seriously it's like but it seems to be
like
i don't know it's like there's like a
random amount of people who are using it
so after experiencing all the pain in
the windows which is an ongoing hell
basically so it's never finished
finished like something new every
couple of weeks uh usually when
microsoft publishes a node.js
you know article in their msdn magazine
there's a new flood of people
to use node.js
at least like i had uh the possibility
of working a little bit on large things
right so one of the things that i really
enjoyed was like getting
uh the arm build to work properly right
so you can run it on raspberry pi
and that was really good fun and i
learned a lot about like how memory
alignment is different between
arm and x86
so considering all that you know like
what kind of regrets do i have when
when having dealt with this project over
four years
right so i think most of the things i
really regret is doing this
i don't know if like this can be
considered an anti-pattern
but it's definitely not good if you're
dealing with something like the driver
i should have done this right
and the lessons from that is really if
it's possible to access an intern the
internal state of something
people are going to access the internal
state of something
and it's just like getting tickets where
people are like oh my application
doesn't work because i'm using this
internal field to find some state of the
driver
and that field is no longer there it's
not kind of fun right
so like the lesson at least from the
perspective of this is like is that i
guess it's the global lesson when it
comes to apis
which is like only exposed state and
functions
that you explicitly want the user to use
now this was more the fact that i was
like completely new to javascript and
that was what i started with
so i'm kind of trapped between this
situation that i actually have to do
backwards compatibility drivers are
supposed to be one of the most
boring things you use it should just
work
right so changing code that breaks
people's applications is a no no
other things that i really did bad was
like i actually exposed the collection
class and i exposed the cursor class
leading people to do
create instances of these and they were
never supposed to be used to be created
instances because they are actually just
kind of internal classes
and i'm still paying for this with
github issues
so if there's lessons here it's like
just be very careful about what you
exposed and then slowly increase the
exposure if you need over time
testing as well is something that's
incredibly painful when you're doing
something like a driver
so in the start i was using simple
integration tests you know
take a document put it in the database
read it back and test right
and i was using jspec and then i moved
to like the n
j unit clone end unit and then after a
while this reality kind of hit me
the thing is like my testing is not a
linear thing
it's a grid so i have to test against
node 08
0 10 whatever the next version is and
there's like several different versions
of mango each of them having slightly
different
features or slightly changes in behavior
and making this
all work in a unified integration
framework is just
horrible right so
what i did was like i had in the end
throw out any unit because it didn't
work anymore and then slowly
working on like a new test framework
just
specifically for integration testing so
the
main core of the idea is to split the
configuration
of what you're testing away from what
actually is the test
and also being able to specify
tags for the test so that you're able to
say this tag needs to
have the server you know support at
least version 2
2 for example and and only run it when
one two two is present
so that you can split up your test and
run them in the grid right so you want
to
run against multiple things you need to
be able to write a test with the least
possible amount of pain but still be
able to give
the runner some sort of uh metadata that
lets it basically
run it against the right version um
and and another thing was like some
things are really painful
like example a replica set like when you
bring down a server
it takes a while for it to stabilize and
bring it back up so
running a lot of tests was incredibly
slow right so paralyzing the test was
also important
not paralyzing as in running the
multiple servers out there
just being able to run them in parallel
using multiple processes on
on the machine for example so that's
also an ongoing thing
but we all know for example that one of
the most painful things
over a long period project is that your
test
code grows uncontrollably because you
never prune your tests
ever how many here have actually gone
back when we factor the tests and remove
tests in the last couple years
couple people right but you all know the
problem right
it's like after a while you don't know
which tests overlap in functionality
anymore
and that's if you're lucky and you're
only one person working on the project i
can't imagine if you're a team
so one of the things i also want to work
on for this particular thing is what i
call reverse
code coverage so instead of asking the
question like
given an x amount of tests what code is
covered by it i want to ask the
different
questions the reverse question i want to
ask given a function which
tests cover this function and then be
able to delete
functions so this is like basically i
think i probably have about 30 40
percent
crap tests so if i could just delete
that i would be
golden hopefully somebody else will be
able to use it after that
the other thing when you're driving
something like an open source project
that everybody uses
it's like documentation and we all know
we love to do documentation because
that's not painful at all to do right
so what people ask for when you're using
a driver examples just tons and tons of
examples give me an example how to do x
right and i realized that i already had
those
in code right because i had the
integration tests
so i decided to build some tools which
are a bunch of
spaghetti spaghetti.js that i need to
refactor and using the python sphinx
library
and what i basically did is very simple
so i added like
the meta data
types myself using the i think it's like
js doc
parser and i basically have a concept of
something called
class like underscore class where it
says this belongs to this particular
class
and this particular function and then
what what it does
is that it goes down through this file
finds the doc
doc line which is just a line that gets
added specifically for
for the documentation and then basically
just
rips that particular piece out of it and
generates documentation with with using
the
merging in the integration test in the
documentation
it's still a bit like like you know
fairly verbose up there so there's still
things i need to fix
but the idea was basically simple if i
add a new test
and i want to make an example in a
documentation i could just tag it
and then at least i would have a
guarantee that when you copy and paste
that code from the documentation
it would run right so you could i
wouldn't have to like maintain
uh things two places
and then it's like the open source thing
right which is his own chapter
backwards compatibility right as i said
earlier drivers need to
be boring and change is bad in drivers
because it's not like you're some people
are using the drivers
directly but most people are using it
through mongoose plus something else or
whatever and so when you change
something at the fundamental part
at the bottom of the pyramid the whole
change ripples up to the chain and you
create a lot of havoc
and yeah some of the apis that currently
are there suck
and i know it but i can't change them
like that easily because there's a lot
of cold out there
relying on it and it's getting worse for
every day right
and then there's these changes in like
just what's hot in the moments there's
you know hot coffee script one week i
can remember getting pull requests
why don't you rewrite your drive ring
off the script
it's like whatever and now it's live
script like really live script
like we're back to naming it what
javascript was actually called
it better look like javascript
then like it's like the managing part of
the project right
one of the things is just to challenge
people to help
like i really appreciate the appreciated
the blog post that felix
guys nerf wrote about like just giving
projects to people
if you're uh leaving them and i've had
some success with that because i had a
git
uh javascript library it's not great but
it works more or less and i just didn't
have time to work on that so
i managed to basically just give pawn
off to somebody else and that worked
great
but people in general are
lazy right so they want to do the least
possible thing so
one of the things you have to do when
you maintain a project and somebody
sends you a bug or something is
challenge
people to help right try to be specific
about what you need
and then like make sure that you give
credits for pull requests right
like make sure that you are nice back
and then just
ignore flames or criticism they don't
matter they go away after a while
and there's like just ignore bad faith
issues where people are just ranting
they just put a
issue there because they're mad or and i
found that like the general ruler it's
like
wait 24 hours to respond to an issue and
see if they fix it and fix themselves
before you start like commenting on it
because if just basically a lot of
things will just go away because people
didn't really try before they
launched an issue and then your code is
always going to suck
so you basically just have to roll with
it like how many here have actually like
gone
look at the code and say oh the hell
wrote this just to realize that the git
blame was themselves
all right so once you get that then you
understand that code and what is
actual good code is completely objective
and is also
subjective and it's also completely
dependent on where you are
in your learning process right so just
be kind to people
that's like the general rule and usually
they're kind back like
and if they're flamey don't respond just
don't
it's not worth it and i think like as
one thing i've learned at mungo is like
being good at not
responding to flames like
so simple enough wrapping up it's like
if you're going to
have some takeaways from this talk it's
like there's no
static environment like we think that
node.js is fairly
stable now but it's going to change
again and it's going to have like
this little knock-on effect right so
they just live with the fact that
everything is
uh dynamic testing drivers is extremely
hard
and then don't take criticism personally
challenge people to help you most people
are actually
nice and actually are willing to help
and just
credit everybody who helps you in fact
being nice to people
pays back in conclusion it's been like
three and a half years since i released
the code
and it's been great it's been really
busy and up and downs
and now i do it for a full-time job so i
can't complain
i made tons of mistakes underway and i'm
sure to make
lots in the future but i would do it all
i can
and that's it
thank you christian uh opening up the
floor for questions
it's like a reoccurring thing i should
just start on this side
um i don't know if this is reasonable or
possible but i was thinking about the uh
buffering operations when a connection
goes down yeah there could be a
configuration to say prefer memory or
prefer disk and then buffer just stream
it to disk and when the connection comes
back stream that
straight to the socket that's a
possibility i haven't thought about that
i definitely did something that's
interesting but the the main problem in
all of these options is like you have to
make it very explicit so there's not
unintended consequences you
to pull out someone's know yeah yeah
any more questions no
i i like i like how you started that off
with i don't know if this is reasonable
reasonable or possible you know that
something interesting is at least coming
like so many good ideas start that way
you know i thought that was great all
right let's give a round of applause for
christian
you